so so you became a street magician like
how did this happen at a young age right
yes I was a theater kid I started out in
theater and my drama teacher Rob
Mackintosh showed me my first magic
trick where he took a red silk
handkerchief and he stuffed it into his
fist and when he opened his hand the
handkerchief was gone it's a classic
right it's a class you know magic that's
a classic right so like I was hooked
so I bugged him for like two weeks
straight and then he finally gave me the
address to Tannen's magic shop in New
York City yeah my dad gave me $30 I went
to the magic shop and I came home with
this small red handkerchief and my dad
had a heart attack because I spent $30
on a piece of silk and I was like no dad
I'm paying for the secret so then he was
like a supporter and he's been my
strongest supporter watching people like
goofy people like me and that dude like
just being like oh it's the best cuz I
take like with those little tricks I
used to take him out on the streets and
performing on the subway and local parks
and things like that and then by the
time I was 16 I was performing in
nightclubs in New York City Wow so I was
like imagine like this for I I was a
variety act I would like pull out big
birds appear in a burlesque show the 16
year old 16 year old in Texas you have a
trick to show us so right sure let's try
something out this let's do it we'll do
something okay we'll do something with
your mind oh you don't want to go in
there
where viewers crazy this will probably
be creepy but really cool if this will
work
all right here I'm gonna I'm gonna call
out four categories I want you to listen
to those categories and then you're
gonna think about it and choose one out
loud okay so let's start with some good
ones let's do food mm-hmm
beverages celebrities or movies she was
one of those out loud movies movies okay
all right I'm gonna make a prediction
here okay you can't see it but it's okay
a few you see okay cheater
so I'm gonna this is what I'm feeling
here let's do let's do this you guys see
this okay here no you know what I'm
actually this is again this is gonna be
even better watch this okay I'm feeling
this one this is a classic what Kelly
you cannot see this but I'm locking into
this one that's gonna stay right there
and she's gonna stay right there oh this
is serious stuff here's where it gets
really freaky this is where it gets
freaky now Kelly I my prediction is set
there I can't change that that's locked
in I'm sweating for you I know you are
gonna choose any random number and make
this random between 1 and 100 go for it
3 that was random ok 3 look I have my
iPhone I'm gonna unlock this with my
face because I don't want you guys know
my password okay I actually have notes
here I have no pad here I'm gonna open
up my nose my nose
I've things to do birthday list books to
read by the end of the year all that
good stuff that I write down but yeah I
never seek to resolutions so you can see
I said I have a hundred greatest movies
of all time yes take your index finger
and open it up okay perfect if you would
have said number one what does that say
The Wizard of Oz that's a classic yeah
if you would have said number let's go
with 16 that's one of my favorites 16
fourth count Forrest Gump right who
doesn't love for you gonna sit here yeah
but you said the number three scroll
three make sure you can see three don't
say it out loud just look at it I see
three and when I say three I want you to
say the third movie listed there okay
one two three Godfather
yeah gentlemen there is no way there's
no way there's no way the Godfather
[Applause]
would you know pick three unless you're
my volleyball team in Burleson Texas in
why was it that was it that was totally
a oh my god I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this